my guest this week is the primatologist
Dr Jane Goodall famed for her work on
noting the connection between
chimpanzees and humans she now travels
the world with her educational program
and her message next stop is Arizona
aged 88 she's not slowing down and she
describes herself now as an
environmental activist but don't expect
her to be lying down in the middle of a
road and stopping traffic anytime soon
[Music]
Jane welcome to the program thank you so
much for for being with me and with all
of us uh you made some very important
discoveries about chimpanzees early on
in your career which really made your
name and I wanted to start our
conversation today by asking what do you
think we need to remember about what
you've learned from what's been
discovered since uh about our
similarities as species perhaps well I
think the most important thing that I
can say is that you know genetically the
composition of DNA of humans and
chimpanzees differs by only just over
one percent so biologically they're our
closest living relative along with the
bonobo and then behaviorally kissing
embracing holding hands patting one
another
the relationship between mothers and
their growing Offspring which can last
throughout a life of Optus about 65 five
years in the world
and unfortunately they have a dark and
aggressive side just like us and they're
capable of a kind of primitive war and
killing but just like us they have a
loving compassionate and truly
altruistic side so in all those ways
it's very clear
and became clear to scientists that we
are part of the animal kingdom and not
as was said in the early 60s completely
separated
and the chimpanzees really have helped
us to understand our position in
relation to the rest of the animals that
we're part of and not separate from the
Animal Kingdom and is that the point of
of trying to understand how we are
similar that we don't see ourselves as
distinct why is that why is that
important well because
once people decide that animals are near
things as was thought then the way that
they're treated can be extremely
inhumane and as we know now we're in the
midst of the sixth great Extinction and
in many places animal lives are not
valued but then we have to remember that
in many places human lives are not
valued either
and I think the one thing that we have
to think about is that the biggest
difference between us and chimpanzees
and other animals is the explosive
development of our intellect
so it doesn't make sense does it that
the most intellectual creature to ever
walk on planet Earth is destroying its
only home and it seems to me there is
some disconnect between the clever
clever brain and the human heart where
poetically we see love and compassion
and I truly believe anyone head and
heart work in harmony can we humans
attain our true potential and our true
potential is huge just just to go to
that point of of love and our similarity
with with chimpanzees when it comes to
our relationships there is this video
this recent footage of a baby chimp
that's gone viral the baby had to be put
on oxygen for a few days after being
born and it's a video of it being
reintroduced to its mother for the first
time I know you've had a look at this
clip it's really moving uh I mean I say
that as someone who's nearly eight
months pregnant as well but just
watching the interaction when they're
reunited of the mother how quick she is
what did you take from it
well I I was very moved by watching that
and clearly when the mother comes in
she's not sure what's happening she's
been separated from her baby at birth I
believe it was a cesarean and then
suddenly you see the infant move and the
arm reaches up and the reaction of the
the rapid response of the mother the
speed with which she moves over and just
so tenderly cradles that infant in her
arms and she's so excited that she's
kind of rocking but very gently because
she doesn't want to disturb this
precious little life that she has
created and I think it gives us a window
into the chimpanzee mentality the way
that she she just relates as I say to
that newborn infant is incredible does
it bring back memories good memories for
you about working with the chimpanzees
and and being with them every day and
studying them up close well during those
amazing years the best in my life I was
learning something almost every day and
I saw the whole gamut of emotions you
know the loving and caring side and also
the violent and aggressive side I saw
the tenderness of mothers and the older
siblings towards newborn babies I also
saw some females who cannibalized
newborn babies of other females in their
group which still doesn't make any sense
to us
and so when you're watching chimpanzees
you run through the same contradictions
in behavior that we see when we're
looking at human beings because we too
we too behave in unpredictable ways well
I know that you have focused your work
of late more away from animals towards
people towards the environment why did
you make that move
because in 1986 I helped to put together
a conference in Chicago actually and by
that time there were six different
fields study sites studying chimpanzees
when I began it was just me but by 1986
there were other people out there in the
field and the aim of it was to see how
does chimpanzee Behavior differ or not
in one environment to another
but during that four-day conference in
which we learned a lot about you know
chimpanzee culture we also had a session
on conservation and it was absolutely
shocking to see right across the chimp
range chimp numbers were dropping
forests were being destroyed it was the
beginning of the bushmeat trade killing
mothers to steal babies for the
international trade in wild animals for
entertainment zoos and in those days for
medical research by then I'd magically
obtained my PhD in spite of never having
been to college but I left as an
activist and we're talking now just
after the the latest cop 27 Global
Climate Summit of you know most of the
world's leaders am I finding you in an
optimistic or a pessimistic place after
that
well I've attended some of those cop
climate change conferences and you know
if people if countries live up to the
pledges that they make and the
commitments that they talk about and the
eloquent way that they say they
understand that we must keep the rise in
temperature under 1.5 and I've heard
some people now saying two degrees if
these pledges were kept but there has
been a history of pledges being made and
not kept so all I can say is I have my
fingers crossed there's no question
awareness about the danger of climate
change and loss of biodiversity because
these two go together and you know we
depend on the natural world for food
water clothing air everything but we
depend on healthy ecosystems and an
ecosystem is made up of this complex mix
of animal and plant species it's like a
glorious tapestry but they're all
interrelated
so as one species becomes extinct in a
particular ecosystem it's like pulling a
thread from the tapestry and if enough
threads are pulled the tapestry will
hang in tatters and the ecosystem will
collapse
I mean you say you have your fingers
crossed I know you you like to be an
optimist from from all you've said and
you actually say that's a key part of
you know going and keeping going with
the work that you do but say you've got
your fingers crossed after this meeting
it doesn't sound that hopeful I mean you
sound like you want to Hope but not
necessarily that you believe these
leaders will keep to the pledges
well that is where we move away from the
leaders and turn to the people
so that my main reasons for hope we the
Jane Goodall Institute we have a program
for young people
from kindergarten through University and
Beyond it's in 66 countries and growing
hundreds and thousands of young people
they care they get it many many of them
are taking action about climate change
and all of these issues that are so
devastating at the time but they care
and they not only care and say that they
care but they roll up their sleeves and
they take action because they get to
choose the projects that they work on
and they work on projects to help people
to help animals and to help the
environment I was going to say if you're
watching this and you haven't rolled up
your sleeves and maybe you're out of the
education system and you're thinking
what can I do what's the one thing you
think more people could do easily well
easily they could move towards a
plant-based diet easily they could try
and eliminate Plastics from from you
know from their lives easily they could
if for different people it's different
things you know some people want to help
immigrant children for example and
because it's all interrelated all these
problems we face today we need people to
tackle them all so what I feel very very
strongly yes there is indeed hope for
the future but there's a butt there's a
window of time when we can
slow down climate change we can slow
down loss of biodiversity we can improve
health care we can alleviate poverty
which is a great driver of destruction
of the environment as people try to live
but there's about and the butt is we can
do this but we all need to take action
we must stop relying on governments and
the good news the big corporations are
beginning to change
Joan what do you say to people who say
things like well while you know big
countries like China are not meeting
these sorts of commitments these sorts
of pledges not changing their economies
enough to to be different I know you're
talking about coming away from leaders
I'm not going to bother it makes no
difference if I don't recycle it makes
no difference if I eat less meat what do
you say to those people who don't have
that optimism because they look at the
countries and the leaders who are not
doing what you're saying yeah absolutely
and isn't there an expression that's all
over the place saying think globally act
locally it's the wrong way round because
if you think globally as you say we get
depressed and you cannot you cannot look
around at what's happening in the world
today politically socially
environmentally and not feel a deep
depression
but what I say to those people is stop
thinking globally you can't do anything
globally but think in your own Community
what can I do what do you care about go
Inspire others get to work roll up your
sleeves do something and that makes
people feel good I wanted to ask you
said you left that meeting in the 80s an
activist there are a new generation as
there always are but there are at the
moment of environmental activists for
instance in the UK just stop oil the
sunrise movement in America
there are mixed views of that as a way
of trying to change people's minds and
the messages of course in some instances
people have been stopped from going to
medical appointments funerals they've
had their their lives disrupted that's
what protests are meant to do how do you
view that type of activism at the moment
that you'll be aware of I think it's a
huge mistake it's alienating people who
otherwise care it makes them angry and
it it tends to make people think about
all of us who care about climate change
in a very negative way or sort of
branded like you know the old tree
hugger type and so then I can understand
their anger but I cannot condone their
methods I mean here you have maybe
hundreds and hundreds of people who are
doing their best trying to live lives
that are more in harmony with the
natural world and they can't get home to
supper they can't pick up their children
because you've got these ridiculous
activists blocking the road or chaining
themselves to posts and things like that
so for me that is not the right way I
can understand their anger but it's
misdirected I believe would you go as
far as calling those activists as some
politicians have would you call them
criminals no I wouldn't go so far to
call them criminals they're just
um
I don't know they're thinking wrongly
that they're not taking and that's
that's the problem you know if you think
of our species at the mouth of a very
long very dog tunnel and right at the
end there's a little Shining Light
that's hope and between us and that
Shining Light there are all these
obstacles that the ones that I've
mentioned so it's no good sitting at the
mouth of the tunnel and saying I hope
that light comes to us soon no no no we
have to roll up those sleeves and crawl
under climb over and work around all
those obstacles lying between us and the
star and yes there are people working on
every single one of the problems
mentioned and not mentioned but too
often they tend to work in their own
little narrow tunnel and if you don't
see the picture as a whole you may
succeed in your goal but that may cause
problems elsewhere can I ask you a very
very random question just at this point
is it right what I have read that you
were presented as a debutant at
Buckingham Palace at the last one of
those kind of events held there is that
right uh under debutant yes because my
uncle my uncle who had money uh wanted
me presented we had no money we had to
scrounge around mum and I in second-hand
shops to find something suitable to wear
and I was lined up with all these other
debutants ready for the season which
basically a marriage Market yeah and you
know they were saying to me that their
ambition was to be a lady and waiting to
the queen when I said no I want to go to
Africa and live with wild animals they
avoided me I mean it was like I was
shunned like a pariah
well it's quite it's quite a memory I'm
sure because I mean and you used to
travel with your mum didn't you well I
only because I mean the first time I
went to Africa I was on my own and then
when Louis Leakey asked me to study the
chimps the uh Tanzania was Tanganyika
part of the crumbling British Empire and
the British authorities refuse
permission to to take responsibility for
a young girl going out into the forest
alone they said no no no no no no in
Indian they said yes but she cannot come
alone and Mum volunteered to come
wow I bet that was quite I mean I bet
that was quite something for her as well
well she was people say I was Brave she
was Brave she stayed down in the camp
um you know there were spiders and
scorpions and snakes and Buffalos came
by and we had one cook and he very
quickly found a frightfully alcoholic
beverage made of fermented bananas so he
was slightly inebriated half the time I
was up in the hills doing what I dreamed
of doing since I was 10. that's amazing
it's amazing that she supported you like
that and that you were able to do she
was I wouldn't be who I am I mean when I
was 10 and had this dream of Africa
because I was in love with Tarzan
everybody laughed and said you'll never
get to Africa as far away you don't have
money World War II was raging and you're
just a girl but what my mother said was
if you really want to do this you're
going to have to work terribly hard take
advantage of every opportunity and then
if you don't give up hopefully you find
a way and that message I've told to
young people all around the world
particularly in disadvantaged
communities and I wish mum was around to
hear how many people have said Jane I
want to thank you because you've taught
me that because you did it I can do it
too that's incredible it's really
incredible I mean and I you know you
were a very rare as a as a woman as a
young woman in that space But I've read
you you also found that to your
advantage in some ways you've taken it
in Good Humor especially when some
comments I believe were made about your
legs being helpful
well back then you know it was it was a
different world like if somebody made
that comment today oh Jane only got onto
the geographic cover I'm famous and
money because of her legs
it would probably big cause for a
lawsuit back then I just said well if
indeed my legs have got me money to
study the chimpanzees thank you legs
probably the only way to deal with it
back then but like you say where things
were said that would not be said in the
same way or certainly received in the
same way as they are now
um I also liked just reading in terms of
your your life and your ability to
connect with people that pre-pandemic
is it right you hadn't slept in the same
bed for more than three weeks since 1986
uh because of your your travel
commitments meeting friends and and
people around the world
that's absolutely true and because
during the pandemic I was grounded at
home in Bournemouth where I'm speaking
from Bournemouth now and it's the
longest I've been at home it's the house
I grew up in by the way where me and my
sister are and her family
it's the longest I've been there since I
left school but
they it was more exhausting than all
that traveling because I could do up to
four zooms
virtual lectures and interviews and
things like this every day my voice got
exhausted it's changed and you know
there was no respite there was no day
off not one in two and a half years no
holiday
and so the advantage was that I was able
to reach literally millions several
million more people in that way than by
traveling and talking in the different
countries and so the idea was after the
pandemic we'll do more of the static
zooming and less of the travel but it
turns out that I'm doing as much travel
and the zooms so I'm doubly exhausted
you doubled up there uh with with some
of the load what what do you make about
travel uh as that being one of the
things people are trying to cut down or
one of the things they try and control
how do you reconcile that well first of
all our roots and shoots groups are
planting literally millions and millions
of trees secondly
if my arrival in a place didn't make a
big difference
I wouldn't do it but it does so many
people have said well Jane it's
wonderful when you zoom and things but
when you come we get the kind of
inspiration we don't get in any other
way so although I'm on these planes I'm
not on a private plane I'm on a plane
that's going anyway we haven't got to
the stage of you know slowing down our
travel which probably is a Pity but
since I'm making a difference and
hopefully helping to make the world a
better place then I I can live with it
do you think we shouldn't have private
jets
no
I mean I think for some businesses it's
almost necessary especially now post
pandemic the you know the air their
travel is you get
flights canceled you get flights delayed
you can't make your connection are you
going to tell some of the celebrities
and some of the leaders who follow your
work and you get to have audiences with
or they have audiences with you to stop
stop using the private jets the PJs no
I'm not going to tell them
um people need to you know I never have
never been one to confront people
because I think the only way that you
can create change in some of these
people is not to argue with them not to
tell them what they should or shouldn't
do but to reach the heart and how do you
reach the Heart by telling stories
and there's one story which I'll share
with you now is a CEO of a big
international company and he was telling
me that for the last eight years he's
been really trying to get his company to
have ethical practices in all the
different countries for three reasons
one seeing the writing on the wall using
up natural resources in some cases
faster than nature can replenish them
secondly consumer pressure people who
can afford it are beginning to demand
products that have been made ethically
but he said what tip the balance was my
little girl of eight
came back from school one day and she
said Daddy
they tell me that what you're doing is
hurting the plan ahead that's not true
is it Daddy because it's my Planet Dr
Goodall thank you very much for your
time well thank you too and just
remember every single day we live every
one of us makes an impact and we get to
choose what sort of impact we make a
very powerful message to Emerald thank
you thank you and thank you so much for
being with us until we meet again take
care and goodbye foreign
[Applause]
[Music]